people of the internet what is up
retrorecons who are here and we are
getting ready to react live to the new
hogwarts legacy the haunted hogsbeat
shop playstation exclusive quest this is
my very first time seeing the trailer
and we are reacting live here with the
chat i hear it's dark
ooh okay hogsmeade madame mason i
understand you have a shop to sell
i think you will find my gems quite
madame mason
what's the catch
you are wise to be wary
why is your mistress selling the shop
dude this game is so creepy
i don't trust her the lady talking
yo what before you just could not seem
to escape the darkness
oh my goodness
they're actually using those little uh
dummy characters
watch
wait was that the joker
what
okay wait wait the haunted hogs meet
shop playstation exclusive quest
includes additional
dungeon
so this is a whole entire dungeon
shopkeepers cosmetic set and in-game
hogsmeade shop okay wait playstation
exclusive quest ps5 ps4
the haunted hogsmeade shop quest is
exclusive to playstation consoles
through february 10th 2024. okay there
you go good news bad news for the
pc and xbox folks there and nintendo
switch it looks like the game
it is not totally exclusive it is a
timed exclusive which we thought it
could be
but oh my goodness
that was creepy
dude everything like all the new stuff
coming out about this game they are
going all in on the dark arts
wow
super impressed we're definitely gonna
have to do a full breakdown of that
trailer at some point but as always
thank you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon